there's this sort of long-standing feud
between Jeb Bush and Donald Trump to the
Republican presidential candidates and
interestingly enough if you go to Jeb
Bush dot-com on your web browser right
now or at least five minutes ago when we
last checked Jeb Bush dot-com redirects
to Donald Trump's website this is really
really funny and if you look at the
different websites Jeb Bush dot-com is
not actually jeb Bush's campaign website
is official campaign website is jeb 2016
dot-com but reasonable people might say
hey I'm gonna learn about Jeb Bush I'll
go to Jeb Bush dot-com and instead they
will be redirected to Donald J Trump
dot-com the daily caller reported that
Jeb Bush dot-com is writ registered to
fabulous dot-com PTY limited which is a
company that manages domain names and
they notice that the website was updated
on November 21st there are two other
domain names that also incorporate jeb
Bush's name and the word president but
they are not operated by his campaign if
you go to Jeb Bush for president dot-com
it's a blog about a gay couple who owns
the website it's just amazing and Jeb
Bush for president dotnet is used to
oppose Jeb Bush so not Santorum level
problems but some problems for jet
excuse me some problems for Jeb online
yeah I think if the people managing all
your web stuff for your campaign were
competent uh when well before things
started getting rolling they would have
snatched up all these domain names it's
possible though that someone own Jeb
Bush dot-com for a long time it is
banned we we did don't I don't know the
exact history of it that is true yes but
still very funny and I think though I'm
gonna guess that because it redirects to
Trump's website yeah that it was a more
recent thing because who was talking
about Trump before any of this uh you
know election stuff started happening
and as was uncovered this some changes
made to the website another November
21st and that may have been the date at
which the redirect started I have to
tell you I was shocked when I saw the
story I mean that Jeb Bush made the news
again I didn't think we were gonna hear
from him again Louis well he only made
the news again because as
something to do with Donald Trump so I
that Jeb Bush not doing so hot you can
make a pretty good right wing argument
as a result of this Jeb Bush can't even
protect his own name how is he going to
protect any Americans from Isis sounds
sounds legitimate to me Dave I think
that's an actual valid argument he can't
even protect protect his uh his internet
tubes I mean from invasion I'm gonna
protect the United States from invasion
totally flaccid yeah I mean it just uh
it's all making no sense after the break
we will be joined once again by
etiquette expert Murray Dubuque I am
going to run a number of scenarios by
her including a recent dinner that Louis
paid for was meant to be a romantic
dinner between Louis and a young lady
and it did not turn out that well we
will talk to you Etta Kate expert Murray
Dubuque after the break